[Applause]
farid are officials under playing the
global economic consequences of the
coronavirus coronavirus I think most
generally people don't know where it's
going right now
and I think it's probably fair to say
it's likely to get worse at least on the
basis of what we're looking at now see
the Chinese have been very good at
dealing with all the technical aspects
of the problem they started out slowly
because they were trying to then deny it
in sort of very typical of a
dictatorship they initially even in bad
news doesn't travel but then they got on
it they built two hospitals in a week
you know only in China can you do some
well you say hospitals a big room with
beds well that's not a hospital you know
that'll count for there try to
quarantine a lot of people the challenge
I think is what do you do about the
psychological the political
ramifications of what's happening so now
there is this whole movement mostly on
the net of people saying why did the
doctor who alerted everyone to the virus
get punished you know so this the
Chinese are stuck between two impulses
on the one hand they don't like bad news
getting out they want to punish people
for spreading bad news on the other hand
they want to solve the problem and the
two are coming into conflict right now
but so far it does look like again it's
looking at least as bad as SARS they
send us a lot of bad stuff remember the
poison dog food and you know the the
toys leaded the bait that they try it if
I quit
I don't think it's personal bad how will
the Trump reelection teams
$1,000,000,000 disinformation campaign
further polarize our political parties
Ezra ooh
it's not gonna be great so there I think
two things were thinking about here one
is that I am NOT a big believer that all
these Facebook micro targeting efforts
etc work as well as all the [ __ ]
were fed on them says like Cambridge
analytical no evidence it worked at all
a lot of it I mean you ever looked at an
ad online you buy a bike then for three
months something closer maybe like would
you like a bike right and so a lot of
this stuff it looks good ish when it
campaign wins and it turns out to have
not been that effective the issue with
this information
Steve Bannon the the your guests really
have talked about this the way you can
stop the media from being able to report
on anything is to give them so much that
they are trying constantly to report on
everything the thing that Trump
understands better than anyone else in
politics is you flood this zone and then
you can one control the conversation but
to you can make sure that nothing you do
no scandal no issue no effort you can
get that much attention and so you're
just constantly moving to the next thing
the thing the media needs to be able to
do is focus on what is actually
important and that is a hard thing for
the media to do the media is very
distractible it's got a short attention
span and it's way too online so
reporters are always on Twitter are
always on Facebook always chasing latest
controversy and what the Trump
administration is often figured out how
to do is use that almost character flaw
to drive the entire media crazy and
through that to try out the country a
little bit crazy to Nancy Pelosi ripping
up a speech than it is to cover the
facts of what was some more fun it's
more fun because it's just how you feel
right liberals can go we're winning we
owned them drop these beats we're gonna
win is so bad
would be just me but my mother and
mother-in-law spent a lot of time
forwarding around on Facebook all of
these articles when you look at the
sourcing of it you have no idea where it
comes from right it's not a legitimate
source I don't think we can
underestimate the power and quite
frankly if it wasn't powerful they
wouldn't be spending at least in my
stead I don't know to the tune of 6
million a week and and in some cases
targeting certain constituencies online
just to push fake news they built a vast
apparatus on the right of all of these
different accounts that look like it's a
new source only so they can give
somebody the validation that they know
something and they're sharing
information or news which is better than
my political ad or your political ad but
a third party source that looks like
it's validating something true that is
absolutely made up and out of whole
cloth in fairness the Russians ran a lot
of those too for sure but I'm just
saying I I I wouldn't underestimate
particularly in a place where elections
are won in the margins my State 30,000
votes 10,000 votes in a US Senate race
we're not talking about moving a whole
bunch of people here we're talking about
moving a couple of thousand at a time
resulting in 29 electoral votes weekend
but that's a thing I think that
Democrats practically after 2016 got so
freaked out about Russian disinfo that
they forget that the biggest problem
they had in 2016 was having media
covered Hillary Clinton's emails a real
story army way out of report not Russian
me not rushing me my army this media
yeah and the what you're saying is true
but the upside of polarization which I
don't get to talk about all that much is
that in this disinfo campaigns people
don't get moved they're getting so much
information and their own they're
already mostly chosen aside and the
people who are easy to move around to
the extent anybody's easy to move around
they're pretty tuned out of it they're
not the folks on Facebook getting tons
of political news and interest because
we're the people Facebook's algorithm
knows don't like politics or they would
have already more or less chosen aside
so I think people need to worry more
about real news and stories done badly
and a little bit less fake news is a
villain we can all agree on it's bad it
shouldn't be there but it's not the key
thing to worry about in the elect I also
think that should be worried about the
majority of Americans who are registered
to vote and are not turning out to vigor
what is it that we can do to one ensure
that when people go vote their votes are
actually counted and it
wins is the one who actually died but a
lot of people keep talking about how to
turn these Obama trunk voters back to
Democrats when they're not talking about
how to turn the Obama nobody voters
million people if you look at if you
look at Iowa the most distressing news
for Democrats should have been that the
Iowa turnout numbers looked like 2016
not like 2008 2012 in other words the
Obama surge didn't didn't happen I think
it's important this people always think
Trump is enough to bring out the
Democrats no it turns out you need a
positive vision negative energy is not
it's enough you need positive energy
three totally agree
the only other thing I was almost gonna
vote for Bernie no no that was the point
of my end there yeah his people are
obnoxious enough to actually get in the
streets and fight because I mean here's
the next question are there any
solutions to depolarize America is there
a legitimate risk of violent conflict if
we know there totally is that risk and I
don't know how you do polarize America
but I'll give you what I have been
saying but I noticed that was sort of
not a big answer in your but use it they
put it right in the title you know this
is the problem and my solution oh yeah I
know I don't I don't play with subtitles
and I don't play with solution there you
go let me say this about it we are not
going to depolarize America what we can
do is make America work better amidst
polarization and the single biggest
thing we can do to make America work
emits polarization is to democratize
America the only reason that
polarization can break the system so
completely is it when you actually have
a majority the majority still can't
govern the problem is not that people
disagree applause Asians just
disagreement we had that before the
problem is that our system grinds to a
halt emits disagreement you have
McConnell and Barack Obama during
Merrick garland so if you didn't have
things like the electoral college like
the sentence disproportionate way of
representing states like gerrymandering
like the filibuster and so people could
actually come in if they want a majority
of the population that majority can then
have things happen and then the public
could decide do they like it or not like
it we'd have a lot healthier for
politics and people just being angry
that nothing happened and blame shifting
over who's to blame for it no this
happened but it's not gonna happen
I don't believe in solutions
people who wants to do it other Baker's
will be disempowered important to know
what you have I do if you haven't hard
to get Michael Bloomberg Dubai Fox News
[Music]
[Applause]
polarization I think is really too weak
a word it's hate people hate each other
I mean you look at social media it's
it's so much hate a good example of it
is we didn't used to like [ __ ] on people
right when they died I thought what Hugh
Hefner died I saw it last week with when
Kobe Bryant uh right same day they'd
brought up his trial and [ __ ] we used to
like you know wait a little bit they
don't care anymore
I mean Rush Limbaugh now look I'm not
gonna pretend that I haven't been guilty
when the Koch brother died last year
Wow was I mean but he was already dead I
didn't think he could hear it and I
don't think his family's watching Rush
Limbaugh you know yes I'm not a rush
limbaugh fan
he didn't some terrible things but I'm
not going to jokes about that he
defended me after 9/11 Rush Limbaugh did
and I never forgot it
and maybe that's we could just pull back
a little on the dead people and the sick
people how about that as a start
everybody what do you think let's not be
sitting on people who are not cold yet
all right thank you very much let's
party
[Music]
you